wir meine Damen und Herren spielen
Animal Crossing wir werden
beide auf dem unterschiedliche Insel
ziehen und beide versuchen so weit zu
kommen wie es geht und dann unsere
Inseln gegenseitig auch besuchen sollen
wir uns so nennen oder sollen wir unsere
anders nennen
wie hast du deinen Charakter genannt
[Musik]
oh ich muss jetzt meine Insel benennen
hast du schon gemacht
Radio
im Hintergrund sind diese komischen
Dreiecke an der Wand haben
blau weiß und orange ich habe blau weiß
grün orange Leute
wie drehe ich das denn ihr kennt ja
meine Theorie ich finde man muss mit dem
Kopf zur Tür liegen wie drehe ich das
denn jetzt also okay ich habe es gedreht
okay geh mal schlafen
wie schläft man kann es sein dass du
dumm bist
als Dank für die Hilfe mit dem Zelt guck
mal Sandra dafür dass ich Benjamin sein
Zelt da aufgestellt habe habe ich jetzt
eine Cap bekommen
[Musik]
das ist das Geld Leute
die vom Gesicht heraus wie Sandy
der gibt mir nur 1000 Sterne für 999
Unkraut da muss ja 500 Unkraut nee 5000
Unkraut
kein Bock
nein
mein Auge ist kaputt
Leute sowas
und Muscheln und so Westen lässt auch
verkaufen
5300 Sternis
Firma danke
[Musik]
oh Mann
ach ich muss in mein Haus gehen gut mein
Fehler im echten Leben Alter nur beim
Arzt bin ich hier
ist erstmal ein Drittel meines
kompletten Vermögens nur für Medizin
hier ausgegeben also ich würde jetzt
gerne die Bäume hier weg haben erstmal
bei mir vom Haus ich will aber noch mehr
verkaufen
und zwar meine Achse explodiert
Markierung für Eugene
Museum sehe ich halt eher so hier neben
Rathaus oder so
ich musste
gestorben
und mich leise anschleichen kleine Hose
die kriegt das Ding
[Musik]
wie kriege ich denn
Schleuder ich brauche eine Schleuder
Benji aus dem Weg
[Musik]
die ist keine Schleuder ist jetzt weg
ach schon weg
ich raste komplett aus
1000 Sterne Sack ein paar Sekunden
später du hättest das Geld wieder
einpflanzen müssen sag mal wollte mich
verarschen also habe ich jetzt dadurch
dass das Geld ausgegraben habe war ich
wieder was falsch gemacht oder wie das
Geld rauskam war richtig aber das noch
zu machen war falsch
[Musik]
denn die Posts
Gulliver sprechen
[Musik]
ich mache mir in die Hosen
im Auge ich dachte der schenk mir jetzt
was
nee der schenk mir jetzt nichts oh mein
Gott morgen per Post du Vogel wenn sie
gevogel ist dieser
[Musik]
natürlich
Mann
[Musik]
ich liebe dich
Gymnastik
[Musik]
ja Leute sorry das ist jetzt so ein
bisschen abrupt zu Ende geht aber ich
bin seit dreieinhalb Stunden live mein
Essen ist da ich habe übelsten Kohldampf
danke euch auf jeden Fall für den geilen
Stream folgt mir auf Instagram da
kündige Streams immer als erstes
ansonsten auch hier auf Twitch gerne
Reihenfolgen ist kostenlos und ihr
werdet benachrichtigt sobald ich live
gehe ich wünsche euch einen
wunderschönen Abend und wir sehen uns
morgen im neuen Youtube Video wieder
[Musik]